the Joe Rogan experience right
what's up the thing I found about the
Egyptians in Ohio was actually from a
paper that was written it's it's
postulating it I guess they took a lot
of the evidence that had they had been
finding and saying this shows that there
might have actually been Egyptians there
was from 1937 that's when the guy was I
think born this is 40 years ago that
amulet was brass apparently and it was
found near Cincinnati and where I
actually think it might have been
trading trade routes because there was
some like stones that have been found in
various parts of the world that are from
specifically Ohio because it's like a
rainbow shale that was using like
arrowheads and stuff a long long time
ago mmm that area was used to make
weapons like that the first like twelve
thousand years ago when the first people
were kind of in North America but that
area in Ohio also is known as the Stan's
own capital the world and I don't know
if that's related to the Egyptians
that's what the pyramids are made out of
you know hmm there's tons of sandstone
that is very specific to that region
mm-hmm pyramids made of sandstone
I thought so yeah yes there's 21 from
1800 to 1980 21 times the amount of
sandstone that made the Great Pyramid
was shipped out of Ohio to make various
buildings all over the world most of
them United States obviously but all
over the place just where the facts I
found a history of the human we don't
know history we know some only the only
history that we know is the one we go
discover on our own time the one that's
presented to us is not history it's all
lies I was not all all of this some live
on that lost civilization in Grand
Canyon was wait Egyptian the Smithsonian
published some stuff in 1909
I guess that where Ellis came from there
was an article that got written and I
don't know how much of it they proved
orpurt was proven or was just newspaper
was like bait back in the day the more
amazing the artifact didn't match up to
anything on the known record rather than
appearing to be of Native American
origin as one might expect the object
had distinct egyptian or Tibetan designs
could there have been an entire
civilization of Egyptians living here if
so how did they get here Don Todd
not that hard helping a boat man you got
cats that leave Africa and try to come
to Spain all these places or a chicken
wing yeah it is interesting right like
the population of Cuba cube is so
insanely diverse it's right there like
what is the history of that other than
the slave routes like what is the
history of Cuba because Cuba's very
distinct African people living there
mm-hmm the whole Carribean although that
whole area is a lot of African roots to
it but that's just a place that was
conquered by the Spain you know by about
the Cortes is you know those type of
people well what really disturbs me is
there's no way to know exactly what
happened it's like you're piecing things
together based on artifacts and
historical record things that people
wrote down and journals and logs and
there's people that have travelled so
again I've studied it so long ago but I
remember reading primary source from
somebody that traveled with Cristobal
Colon aka Christopher Columbus and he
was saying very specific things about
his accounts when he reached these
different places you know and he was
saying things like we got to the land
and we found Africans and I remember him
specifically saying so no matter where
we go we find Africans and he said it as
if he was disappointed and then he
started talking about like you know this
is they started talking about the
culture and describing their culture you
just got to go look at the people that
travel with Cristobal Cologne and and
there's some first-hand accounts there
and they're very honest about it you
know dude I'm gonna look into that now
that's a very interesting I'm gonna ask
gram about that to what he knows about
it yes he studied me especially on his
latest book he studied a lot about the
various cultures that made it to North
America and South America okay yeah yeah
this is very rich in history very very
much
[Applause]